James is with us in Youngstown Ohio hey
James how are you how are you better
than I deserve what's up in your world I
have three colors always long good lord
one for 45,000 it's worth about 35 36 1
is 14,000 and I think it's worth like 6
and I have a $1,000 loan on the next one
and I just saw that prison that's only
worth 4 mm-hmm and when you say you're
given these values it was appraised you
went to a dealer and asked them what
they would give you for it yeah that's
what the last one I look notice two up
on telework and what were you looking at
wholesale or retail or private sale one
private sale okay all right and what's
your household income 104 and I have
about a 300 with the house and that okay
what other dad have you got other than
these cars not counting your house I
have a Disney timeshare credit card and
I had to get those basement water first
mm-hmm how much do you owe on all of
that there's me I think I owe
proximately eight the basement I owe
approximately 17 it just got done and
the rest is credit-card one of your own
credit cards I owe eighty five hundred
or thousand one hundred hundred and then
the rest is medical bills and how much
do you have a medical bills because I
don't have a rest you said 300 thousand
including your mortgage and I don't have
your mortgage so I can't back out of it
what's your medical bills about four
thousand okay all right and you make a
hundred and four yeah yeah okay so
what's your goal probably where do you
want to do I want to get rid of them I
feel drives Junkers if I could okay well
you can't
credit okay it's maxed out I don't know
I'm just saying is your credit clean
no it's maxed okay who's the loan on a
$45,000 piece of insanity GM financial
okay I would go just go to your credit
union and borrow the $9,000 difference
on a personal loan and sell the crap out
of that car and it actually did the same
thing on the $14,000 car okay I might
keep the eight because you don't get
much ground with it and just put it in
your debt snowball and then begin to
work your debts no well but the $45,000
is gone as soon as I can get the loan
okay cuz it's insanity what kind of car
is that it's a Silverado truck yeah yeah
I had 10,000 negative equity going into
it uh-huh that's a great Drive I mean
not my son one's got silver got another
great truck he owns it though this one
owns you right so it's time to get rid
of it it's it ain't that great yeah we
have negative flow every month because
of all these cars you know yeah but half
of your debt not counting your house is
one car yeah you know so I mean you can
you can plow through this pretty quick
you get rid of that those two cars and
get you one one thousand dollar car keep
the $8,000 one the four thousand dollar
car that's Joey don't keep that one get
you one thousand dollar car dump the
other two and borrow the difference so
you need nine and eight so you need
about $17,000 from the credit union if
you can get that as an unsecured loan or
your local bank that gets you out of
those two and you're just looking for a
personal loan but that drops your debt
way seriously down and then you just
list your debts remaining that's
smallest to largest individual medical
debts individual credit cards not by
category smallest to largest individual
debt and begin to pay them off in that
order as fast as you can but you'll be
back on positive when you get rid of
that debt though those two car payments
because those two car payments are just
outrageous
you just have a mess on your hands and
you
so and then we get after this and tear
our way through it so it looks like
you'll clean up you know some credit
cards some medical cleanup that car
you can sell that timeshare by the way
and Disney is actually one that you can
sell you can call timeshare exit team if
you need to to get out of it but I don't
think you need to Disney time says you
can actually sell so I'd get rid of that
thing and get it sold and get rid of
that that debt as well so sells so much
stuff the kids think they're next dude
that's what it comes down to it's time
to have a bloodletting around your place